i'm abby hornacek this is dr carlson and
i'm jessica tarlov
this is the fox news rundown
wednesday september 9th 2020 i'm john
decker
a norwegian lawmaker is nominating
president trump for a nobel peace prize
for the historic peace agreement between
israel
and the uae it's a tremendous effort and
this could be
to inspiration for other arab nations to
make peace with israel
i'm dave anthony despite a pandemic that
caused a recession
the housing market is booming a home is
no longer a home a home is now a
workplace as well
it's also a school and i think that that
that really
has gotten a lot of people in a position
where they're they've decided to pull
the trigger
and change the condition that they live
in i'm liz peek
i've got the final word on the fox news
rundown
[Music]
each october the recipient of the nobel
peace prize is announced by a
five-person nobel committee which is
appointed by the norwegian parliament
besides president obama three other u.s
presidents have won the nobel peace
prize
president theodore roosevelt in 1906
president woodrow wilson in 1920 and
president jimmy carter in 2002.
today president trump has been nominated
for the peace prize for 2021
just weeks after helping to broker peace
between israel and the united arab
emirates the nomination was submitted by
christian tybring jetty
a member of the norwegian parliament who
lauded president trump for his efforts
in solving protracted conflicts
worldwide
he has done what alfred nobel said he
was supposed to do
if you want to get the peace prize
christian tybring jetty is a member of
the norwegian parliament
in alfred nobel's will he's stating
three
three conditions the first one is
fellowship among nations
and he has done that uh through all
these uh
negotiations between nations uh it's
reduction of standing armies
he has reduced the number of troops in
the middle east
and the third criteria is promotional
peace congresses and his latest
effort which resulted in the peace
between the uae and israel
is a tremendous effort and this could be
to inspiration for other arab nations to
make peace with israel
it's really worth the nobel peace prize
this recent
effort this recent as the administration
will call it success
concerning israel's recognition of the
uae and uae's recognition of israel
share diplomatic relations why do you
believe it's so significant
if you look at the the history of the
middle east and
and israel it's been also a hostile uh
conditions for
as long as you can remember and um
if you know the history you know that
you know the conditions both in the arab
world and in israel and uh and you look
at the other
um other people that have gotten the
peace prize
they have do you need the oslo accord we
did dealing in the middle east and also
the camp david agreement
in 1979 is also dealing with the uh
these efforts in the middle east meaning
that it's a very very important region
in the world
and all efforts that leads to peace in
that region should be awarded with a
nobel peace prize and also for donald
trump trump well it certainly is
historic
the third arab country to uh exchange
ambassadors to establish embassies in
the state of israel
and in fact the white house announcing
that it will have an event commemorating
uh this peace agreement at the white
house
next tuesday another reason that you say
president trump
deserves this honor of the nobel peace
prize is because of his efforts
concerning north and south korea can you
explain that a little bit
yes donald trump was the first one to be
able to talk to the north korean leader
and uh i think he has a uh let's say an
un-diplomatic way of getting in touch
with people and talk to people
and in this uh instances what a good
thing
and also south korea and north korea
they could talk together and it wants to
to get rid of north korea's nuclear
weapons and i think trump is uh
had started on that effort i think is uh
the first one to do that
i know that the former south korean
leader just got this
peace uh um peace prize just by
talking to north korea here's actually
talking to both of them and getting to
talk to each other and i think that's uh
honorable and it's actually an
achievement
when people hear the news that the
president has received the nomination
for the nobel peace prize
there are some here in america and also
in norway and around the world who may
be surprised and they may be surprised
because
uh they don't view the president perhaps
in the same manner that you do as a
peacemaker
they may see the president because of
his tweets because
of the things that he says as not very
unifying
is that a factor that the nobel peace
prize committee should take into account
as they consider
uh their recipient for 2021
i think they will will take that into
account but i don't think they should
because you have recipients of the peace
prize and the recipient of other
nobel prizes that has gone to people
with a personal record that nobody
really knows but they're getting it for
achievements of what this prize is all
about
is it a piece or it's physics or it's
mathematics or literature
you don't ask for the personality of the
people you just ask the performance of
the people
and donald j trump has performed very
well internationally
what he does in internal domestically is
uh it's not a it's not of the
price of peace price matter and i
understand that many people
dislike the president trump but i guess
many people disliked arafat when he got
the peace prize also
so that doesn't matter it's actually
what you achieve in international
diplomatics and
and donald trump has proven that he is
worthy
the nobel peace prize there have been
four u.s
presidents who have received the nobel
peace prize the most recent being
president barack obama less than a year
into his presidency
how would you evaluate uh president
obama's
accomplishments leading to his
being awarded the nobel peace prize in
his less than
first year in office versus president
trump
in his first three and a half years in
office
i think most people were surprised when
obama was given the peace price i um
and i and i think obama uh was probably
the most surprised
of all of them and he also said so and i
think the peace prize
was given to obama because the nobel
peace committee leader was very
flattered and also very impressed by
obama's speeches
and how he behaved during the first
month in office as a president
and also he was the first black
president this was also
an achievement in himself i think that's
what the nobel peace prize committee
considered but i think that is not what
the peace prize committee should
consider it's just
achievements not uh any other criteria
are you a fan christian of the president
are you a fan
of what he's done so far as president
i think he had a very very difficult
term i think the first couple of years
he did a very good job creating a
17 million jobs for minorities and women
and
was really doing really well and he was
actually
hit by the covet 19. maybe he didn't
tackle that that well
and and also he has also been hit by
the black class matter uh movement and
uh
he he's unable to control that but
that's not his job either i think there
are mayor governors
he's not able to control those uh riots
and it's not the president's fault so
all that said i know that he could have
done better but i think he has done
fairly well
give me a sense if you could and i
realize you're an outsider but it's 55
days
until the presidential election to what
extent do you think that
uh this nomination of president trump
for the nobel peace prize
may impact the presidential race uh do
you think that uh
undecided voters uh may be swayed in any
way seeing the president in a different
light
well i i hope so i think it's getting a
really really uh
negative uh all kinds of negative words
written about
don't trump and in norway every morning
we wake up to news about something
negative about
donald j trump no one is talking about
biden's efforts or finance as a
candidate so i i think it's good that's
way some voters to go republican
and and uh so knowing that there are a
few
at least some europeans who think trump
is doing a good job maybe it could help
some to
actually vote republican instead of
working democratic
i asked you about whether or not
american voters may be swayed by this
nomination
what's your sense about the nobel peace
prize committee
they are committee of five appointed uh
by
the norwegian parliament of which you
are a member do you think that they
may be swayed uh by the arguments that
you make in your nomination letter
i'm not sure about that but i think
there's gonna
maybe reconsider a little bit to how
they think about the world
and they should ask themselves what's
most important is it to create peace or
is it to be a
a person who is actually uh provoking
domestically and that's not the point
they should look at the records and the
record shows that
donald j trump has achieved peace in
many places in the world
and those efforts has not been
successful by other leaders
other prime ministers or presidents
earlier
but he has done it and that's what they
should look at as a peacemaker
and of course that is what the nobel
peace prize is all about
as a peacemaker in your view how does
president trump stack up to
uh his predecessors the people who have
previously served in the oval office
if you look at the record uh donald
trump has done a good job
um because they're also focusing on the
negative
about donald trump so if you look at the
positive side
being withdrawing troops from the middle
east um
people would say that uh wouldn't think
about that as a peace effort but it's
actually a peace effort
less fewer soldiers outside of their own
borders of course create more peace than
if you have soldiers outside your
borders
and that was alfred nobel's also a
vision and the same uh
same about if you talk to people i think
donald trump has a
an ability to actually talk to leaders
so all kinds of leaders if it's a
putin or if it's a north korean leader
or leaders of uae or israel or anyone
he's able to do that and they're not
making it so
complicated you actually talk to them i
think it's easier to make peace
even with the worst enemies christian ty
bring jetty thank you so much uh for
sharing your views on uh your nomination
of president donald j
trump for the nobel peace prize of 2021
we'll be watching closely to see if the
nobel peace prize committee is listening
and
paying attention to what you've made
clear in your nomination letter thanks a
lot
christian really appreciate it thank you
very much
[Music]
bye-bye
this is liz peek with your fox news
commentary
coming up this corona virus crisis
has affected us all in a variety of ways
for a lot of people it has meant finding
a new place to live
a few research survey found 22 percent
of americans have either moved
temporarily permanently or know someone
who has
one big reason losing a job and not
being able to pay
rent the turner institute came up with a
survey
that estimated just in the state of
california that renters specifically as
a class
in this state have experienced anywhere
from a 50 to 66 percent drop
in their income democratic governor
gavin newsom signed a bill extending
protections from being evicted
through february people that can we
would like to see them make
a partial rent payments over the next
number of months roughly 25 percent
at least and the trump administration
through the centers for disease control
also ordered an emergency federal
eviction moratorium for americans who
qualify
through december 31st and while all
those people suffer through bad times
these are very good times for many
homeowners
the housing market is booming new home
sales rose 14 percent in july
previously owned home buying surged
nearly 25 percent to a pace
not seen in over a decade and those
selling
are getting much higher prices up 19
in philadelphia compared to a year ago
with double digit increases also from
boston to cleveland to kansas city and
realtors
love it i'd listen dave i can't complain
mike aubry
is vice president of compass real estate
in the washington dc area
i i think if anybody thought going into
a global pandemic that we would see
real estate react in the way that it has
they would certainly be sitting on a
beach somewhere drinking something
fruity with an umbrella
right now because they would have made a
ton of money based on knowing that up
front
you know back when all this was going on
you know march and april with all the
shutdowns
you couldn't even get together with
anybody to go look at a house right
well actually in my area specifically
um we were labeled as uh as essential
personnel so i never quit working i did
change how i was working um in that uh
obviously uh i was one of the very early
adopters of ppe
even before uh it sort of became the
norm that it is now um
and i also think that i started to rely
pretty heavily on technology in real
estate and that people really
looked to see properties in any way that
they could
you know whether it be a 3d tour or a
video tour
or me being there doing a personalized
face time with somebody before they
actually wanted to
set foot in the house but no i i never
slowed down and i never quit working
certainly not in the in the dc region
are people more and more buying homes
they don't actually set foot in
um have i had some people who have
purchased homes without ever actually
looking at one
um certainly since the advent of this
pandemic i have believe it or not
um and uh you know again i think that
that relies heavily on the technology
that has become the backbone of real
estate at this point i i think that uh
that added to the fact that people are
fearful
about where they're going and and you
know don't want to get sick
i think that that while not stepping
foot in the house
and buying it certainly isn't the norm
yet i think we're seeing it a lot more
than we ever have
okay so what is it that caused the boom
for the market as we went through the
summer pre-pandemic
there we were already at uh we were in a
situation where we did not have enough
inventory
based on the amount of need that was out
there
builders have been behind the eight
balls for years now
so we sort of came into this thing
with lack of enough inventory anyway the
pandemic caused
uh everyone to re-evaluate where they're
being quarantined and if they have to be
quarantined again
where are they going to be quarantined
and i think that that you know
you uh you look at the fact that that a
home is no longer a home a home is now a
workplace as well
it's also a school and i think that that
really has gotten a lot of people in a
position where they're
they've decided to pull the trigger and
change the condition that they live in
there's been a lot of stories about
people leaving cities
looking into the suburbs or looking into
the country
is that real for the sake of this answer
let's not talk about new york city or
san francisco
okay my answer plainly to you is no we
are not seeing that
do i think that that there are people
who have
decided to move out of urban centers
absolutely but listen
again sort of back to this idea of what
happened before the pandemic
the reality is the largest buying group
is the millennial buying group
and based on demographics and household
formation the millennials
who were the people who drove
urbanization in the first place
are now starting to marry they're
starting to have kids and they're
looking at bedroom communities because
they want better schools and they want
sort of a different way of life
than what they've been living in the
cities and and that was happening before
covet so i i think that they were
beginning to
sort of look at going into those spaces
dave and then it was just exacerbated by
kobe but the reality is
is that the next up and coming
generation as well as the boomers
are now looking to be in cities anyway
so as those millennials
begin to sell their houses it's not like
there's not somebody in line to buy it
we have a tough economy for a lot of
people
there have been estimates that a third
of americans have missed a rent or a
mortgage payment during this crisis
so you see a housing boom you have a lot
of people who are struggling i don't
that doesn't necessarily follow each
other
most buyers and and in this case most
owners didn't lose their job where we
really are seeing unemployment
in the country right now is from hourly
workers and those weren't the people who
are owning or buying houses anyway
those you know i i think that certainly
my client base
uh that i work with what i'm seeing is
those people are doing move-up buys
meaning that they're buying bigger and
better because they didn't lose their
jobs
so then the problem in the the
difficulty in the economy
is more with the people who are renters
there's big trouble
coming for people who are renters right
now
um i think that anyone who is taking
advantage of rent abatement
likely absolutely needs it um i i think
that you know these are the people
who we see who we used to see in
restaurants
and places like that and of course you
know that that
sector has been absolutely decimated by
this pandemic
those people are in a bad way in terms
of the money that they have
and and i think that you know this
certainly
has a potential to be a real looming
crisis for the economy and the country
at the same time in your business i'm
just i'm assuming you're seeing bidding
wars and houses come and go off the
market in a couple of days now
let's talk about the last house that i
put under contract
um i put that property on the market
it had 70 showings in two days
got seven offers and went 40 000 over
asking price
holy cow right i mean it is an
absolute smoke show in the marketplace
right now and low mortgage rates
have added a lot of fuel to that fire
really low
since the corona shutdown's hit in
mid-march rates have dropped from 3.65
percent
for a common 30-year fixed-rate loan to
under
3 last week it's back over that now
slightly
the 15-year mortgage a popular choice
for many who have refinanced in recent
months
is around two and a half percent you
know you want to try to catch rates as
low as you can
because eventually they will go up
although i can tell you from my
perspective
and certainly from my forecast i don't
see rates moving
up for quite some time now and i think
it's you know
jay powell and uh and uh his uh
colleagues are gonna probably keep that
in what i'm saying could be likely the
truth
right because the federal reserve isn't
going to act until the economy is doing
much better and overall
we don't know how that recovery is going
to happen in the next six months yet
i would agree although and you know just
to take you back to another reason why
real estate is doing so well
i think that we are going to see the
advent and the return of real estate as
an asset class both
from uh the individual perspective and
the institutional investor i think that
there's some real worry about
what's happening in the securities
market right now and i think
what's a better place to park your money
than in real estate at the same time
though
our investors they usually don't love to
buy
when things are expensive and we have a
10 percent
year-over-year gain in the median price
of a home in august up to around 350
000 that's national i know every
market's different
but they're buying on the high end right
now as an investor
i would agree but i mean i think that
that as an investor the play
is and you know you know this whether
you're investing in real estate or
you're investing in securities the play
is that you get rid of your risk based
on
longevity meaning that it's a long-term
play the idea of buying it right now and
selling it in six months is not what i'm
talking about
that was the sort of unhealthy
marketplace that we saw pre-lehman
i think that when i talk about uh
institutional or individual investors
moving into the sector
i think that those are people who are
moving into the sector for a long play
all right you mentioned lehman of course
the big housing bubble burst in the 2000
range we're now seeing the annualized
rate as of july for new home sales
and the much bigger part of the market
to previously own home sales the
strongest pace since 2006
so that dates all the way back it does
but
listen i i think i want you to remember
that that
the big difference between pre-lehman
and now
is underwriting the dodd-frank act and
the fact that what we're not doing is
we're not putting bad paper in the
street
as much as people want to worry about it
i've never seen underwriting standards
as high as they are right now
and so most people are in a position
where they're not going to likely
default
is this a tougher time though for a
first-time home buyer who
doesn't have a huge income but is trying
really hard to buy a house
brutal it is absolutely brutal i can
tell you
that you know again one of the most
underserved
areas in the marketplace right now is
first time
building um i think that the margins are
not there for builders and so they tend
to build bigger and better things that
have greater margins
i think what a lot of times the the
marketplace forgets
is that you start down low and it sort
of
trickles its way up the market meaning
that
we want first time home buyer housing
because
as those people buy the people who they
are
buying from are going to buy bigger and
the people they're buying from are going
to buy bigger etc so forth and
and you know i visa v a strong market
comes from a strong base including entry
level housing
with the giant sales increases and the
price of a home increasing is that short
or long term in your view
do i think that if we see demand begin
to give way some
that that can lead to a flattening i do
do i see us
dumping off of a cliff just to go back
to that that
sort of pre-lehman conversation i don't
i think that that
we have a relatively stable market at
this point
uh that i you know that is not at risk
of big drops
so uh you know i i think that
uh that we are probably in a position
that real estate
is going to continue to be sort of one
of the safe places
in our economy well that'll keep you
busy that's for sure makes me happy dave
i'm sure it does mike aubry vice
president for compass real estate thank
you so much for joining us
it's my pleasure
[Music]
getting schooled is a podcast hosted by
fox nation's abby hornacek each week
abby and her expert guests tackle topics
we take for granted and help explain the
roots and meanings behind them subscribe
and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcast.com
america is listening to fox news
subscribe to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com
it's time for your fox news commentary
liz
pete what's on your mind democrats are
panicked that a covet vaccine will
emerge
right in time for the election boosting
president trump's chances
they and their liberal media enablers
are scrambling to undermine that
prospect by sowing fear
and distrust about a vaccine any vaccine
even before one becomes available how
heinous is that kamala harris in a
recent
cnn interview said she would not take a
vaccine
unless it had been vetted by medical
experts saying
she would not quote take president
trump's word for it unquote that the
medication was safe
good news senator harris president trump
is not going to give you that shot
your doctor will do that the new york
times has been helpfully stoking
concerns for months publishing articles
like
quote mistrust of a coronavirus vaccine
could imperil
widespread immunity which argues that
the rapid timetable
and president trump's cheerleading are
creating a whole new group
of vaccine hesitant patients yes just
like the new york times article
such is the misinformation campaign
being waged by anti-trumpers
that the leading developers of a vaccine
pfizer moderna
johnson johnson glaxo smith klein
and sanofi have announced in a recent
public statement
pledging they will not release a vaccine
unless it is safe
that's reassuring because we actually
thought major international pharma
companies would be happy to poison
millions of americans
just to please president trump as joe
biden might say
come on man the effort to shake
confidence in a vaccine began
months ago when president trump ramped
up operation warp speed
which according to the hhs website aims
to deliver 300 million doses of a safe
effective vaccine for coven 19 by
january 2021
as part of a broader strategy to
accelerate the development manufacturing
and distribution of covet 19 vaccines
therapeutics and diagnostics the all-out
battle against the coronavirus has
engaged the cdc
the fda and also many private companies
in late march for example hha's
announced 456 million dollars had been
directed to j
j to accelerate clinical trials for its
candidate vaccine
moderna and astrozenica also receive
funding
the objective is to fast-track
development of a vaccine by speeding up
the approval process
and patient trials which can take years
and cost
up to two and a half billion dollars the
haste
is not a campaign ploy it is to save
american lives
for sure if president trump and his team
were not pushing full
tilt for a vaccine which to date has
killed nearly 190
000 americans joe biden would be
outraged
he recently tweeted mr president it's
time for you to get to work and control
the spread of this virus
joe has promised if elected to call for
nationwide mass
mandates from which he has now retracted
and to accelerate the development of
treatments and vaccines
yep just like president trump is doing
months ago before
everything covet had become politicized
the new york times
ran a piece by dr perry class entitled
quote coronavirus
vaccine dreams in which she celebrates
the life-saving
and world-changing benefits delivered by
inoculations against
polio for example she wrote
if we get a vaccine for the coronavirus
it will immediately make our world a
safer
easier more reassuring place once again
that's what vaccines do tragically
that's exactly
what democrats fear i'm liz peake
[Music]
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute news
go to foxnews.com
[Music]
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust
and click the fox news rundown playlist
for the latest episodes